right so here I'm going to show you
slowly this hand the thumb goes down
this hand the thumb is up
if you don't do it like that
you don't end up with what I call the
outward one you end up
so some of you have been doing it and
I've noticed that you're getting the
first part and then this hands come in
underneath the hand so there's no
there's no contact anymore all right so
so
it's really high level so if anybody's
getting it under about third down you're
doing really well you know
you have to keep practicing perhaps here
until it's you don't have to practice it
anymore then we've got haven't we
we've got either here now he could take
off while I'm running in
or you can use that energy this here to
keep him going
for the Roman Aggie
so you don't even show you anymore
you've got your women Aggie okay